As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, dear brothers and sisters.
As we watch what is unfolding today in
Gaza, we have to understand that
opposition is counting on us to lose
attention, to become fatigued, and to
move on with the new cycle. And just as
we can't allow them to dictate our
attention, we also can't allow them to
dictate the pace of our solidarity. And
part of that solidarity is going to be
there to rebuild Gaza, short-term,
long-term. I am proud to give my
support, my word of support to trusted
brothers and sisters in the United
Kingdom that have started a walk, that
have started an endowment to make sure,
inshallah ta'ala, that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be
long-term, and we will not forget our
cause in Palestine. We will not forget
the cause of Al-Aqsa, and we will not
forget bidhnillah ta'ala our brothers
and sisters in Gaza. Jazakum Allahu
khairan. As-salamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh do these people know that you
have a tumor in your brain?
Well, it's I don't know. Do I don't
know.
Okay. So, is this is this we can cut it
out?
>> it's it's you can keep it in. That's
Okay, okay, good. So, can we just
explain that because not many people
know that cuz obviously I've spoken
about my eye condition and so losing my
eye vision.
Um
with you, mine's I your one is affecting
the brain. Yeah, whatever is left of it.
No joking. So, okay, so can you tell us
about when did you have this tumor in
your brain? What kind of impact does it
have? Um cuz you do I need to take
specific medication, if I'm not
mistaken. I used to take amitriptyline.
Uh okay.
Now, I don't take anything for it.
>> Okay, okay, when did you have
>> It's since when? Just a quick break on
the podcast, brothers and sisters. As
you guys know, at Salat Pro, we are
teaching thousands of people to learn
how to pray salah through our one-to-one
salah instructors, through 150,000 mats
that we printed in six, seven different
languages that we distribute to da'wah
tables, to prisons, to mosques, to
hospitals, to schools. And subhanallah,
we have our salah hubs that we open
across
the world. Alhamdulillah, we got the
Salat Pro app, and we could not do this
without Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, and
thanks to your amazing donations. If you
would like to teach someone to learn how
to pray salah from sisters, go to the
link there inshallah. 100 pounds will
teach 20 to 60 people to learn how to
pray salah, learn surah fatiha, learn
how to do wudu inshallah. Let's get back
to the podcast. Enjoy inshallah, but do
go and check that link and donate
whatever you can. It was discovered last
13. I don't know if it's it's not not
growing. It's like
like they they've looked at
at it and stuff. It's not really but
some doctors have said this is the cause
of some severe migraines that I get.
Okay. Now, the migraines that I get are
really really bad.
They're kind of like
debilitating. Yeah. To the point where
I've had to go to the hospital so many
times like
which you've seen.
And I think and I think it's I always
called them to give me the morphine as
soon as possible. Give me the morphine.
Like I Well, one time it was Ramadan cuz
what triggers it a lot is
other dehydration. Yes. So, Ramadan is
so hard for me because I get like some
Sometimes I get headaches but sometimes
just
you know, I feel really weak or If you
think about it, you're actually exempt
from doing it but you still do it cuz I
can remember I had that discussion with
you when we were on a dawah trip. And I
said, "Bro, like you are exempt but he
was like Allah said it is Sometimes I
like traveling and there's a Ramadan
to give myself a few days rest cuz it's
so hard and So, you can make it up.
Yeah. And like I try to make it up at
these kind of times, you know.
What's the plan Allah? You know, God
knows subhanallah. I be personally the
relation we have with the Quran like for
example you said your mom and your
auntie taught you Yeah. how to read the
Quran. That's
admirable. That's admirable. I'm glad
that they taught you the Quran. I
actually do believe bro that had an
impact on your life that that not
growing. Might be. It's like the
headaches thing is honestly like I've
realized electrolytes helps a lot, water
helps a lot.
Like drinking a lot of water is
in my If I'm being good, then I'll drink
3 to 5 liters a day of water. You know,
I mean quite a lot of water.
Um Okay. So, the the headaches thing was
this really bad pain and um
I used to be given like
uh
like constant medication for it.
They gave me amitriptyline. I don't know
why they gave me amitriptyline because
it's also it works as an old school
antidepressant. They used to give me 10
10 mg of it a day. Yeah. But it wasn't
it was like skills for me. It wasn't
doing anything. So I just I stopped I
stopped it for a while and I thought
well
I don't need this
nothing for me nothing changed.
But they've given me different things
for it actually. They've given me
multiple medications for it and stuff.
But it would I would be I would say that
even though I've had pulmonary embolism
I've had multiple breaks in my body.
I've broken my jaw. Yeah. I've broken my
jaw in three places. I've got two
titanium plates in my jaw. Yeah. I've
I've broken my So you don't have a glass
you don't have a glass jaw.
I've broken my hand multiple times. I've
broken my knees multiple times
both both of them actually.
I've torn them all but this and I've had
the pulmonary embolism which is like
Yeah.
>> life or death. But the the pain of the
head Yeah.
That that one was the worst. That is the
worst. If if I get hit with that
headache is so bad. The last time it
happened I think it was a year ago. I
was in the hospital and I just couldn't
handle it. They gave me um
They gave me
morphine. Okay.
In the hospital
I took morphine.
And I think it might have been Ramadan.
I took morphine and I took another
opioid I can't remember what they gave
me and it wasn't working. No way.
Nothing was working on this thing.
>> that's crazy.
>> It's like you know morphine is a strong
drug. They they gave me morphine. They
gave me opioid. Gave me this and that
just wasn't working. It was bad.
That kind of pain is is I think in a way
it's good because it's
pain tolerance in it. Like it helps you
get
>> Yeah. Yeah. It does it does.
This card is a card that everybody be
waiting for. What's one THING THAT'S
HARAM?
>> I DO BELIEVE PEOPLE, BUT I DON'T THINK
THE people that the Sharia is intending
here.
>> Saying that all Palestinians, they are
responsible. This man is being more
slippery. He's being more slippery than
the lubricant that he sells in his
daughter's sex shop.
I would want to escape from fame. I
don't mind going to countries with very
low Muslim populations. What do you
dislike most about your personality?
>> I'll just assume that you went to the
shura. I think you're controversial. I
wouldn't do that. So is the ambassador.
Why don't you Why didn't you introduce
her in that manner? So why didn't you
introduce me as the Oxford graduate?
So would would you marry a Muslim jinn?
Why why would I? What would I get from
that? I'm just asking you. Why are you
asking me? Why are you blaming me?
Blame the one who asked the question.
Who asked the question?
Absolutely pathetic.
Let's play a game.